ben affleck and anna de armas recently
called it quits
and now a source is telling e.t his ex
jennifer garner is standing by his side
for support
quote ben is happy healthy and doing
great since his breakup with anna
ben's friends and jen garner are
supportive of him moving on
those close to ben thought the
relationship wasn't working for either
of them anymore
i really admire ben and jen split in
2015
after 10 years of marriage and finalized
their divorce
in 2018. the two share three children
together
with everything going on you and jen
always still manage to co-parent how do
you guys make all of that work
we do our best we never try our best now
e.t source says moving forward
the oscar winner is taking some time for
himself and for his family
quote for now he's taking care of
himself and focused on his kids
ben and anna still text regularly and
communicate
so who knows what the future will hold
for them another source
previously told et that the couple's
split was a mutual decision
after they decided the relationship just
wasn't working the way they both wanted
it to anymore
they both have a lot of love and respect
for each other but it was time for them
to move on
at the end of the day he chose to be the
dad he continues to want to be
unfortunately they are in different
places in their lives
last year before his relationship with
anna went public
ben opened up to e.t about what he's
looking for in a potential partner
well i don't know i think a trust and
care and mutual respect and you know
al all the sort of usual stuff but but i
think that's a big part of
what makes life satisfying and
interesting it sort of happens when it
happens though you know it's not the
kind of thing you can
you can force
you